pas besoin d'être à l'épreuve des balles
pour être une super héroïne les femmes
noires ont toujours eu des super pouvoir
endurer la malle pour avancer
parle elle n'a pas besoin d'un héros
elle a besoin d'une reine
ah non je veux qu'on fasse des miracles
harlem la ville entière sera tpiy je
peux être la mère que tu voulais que ce
soit
des armes
c'est vraiment de là que vient notre
argent il est grand temps pour nous
d'enterrer les fantômes
maria doit disparaître je veux sentir
l'odeur de sa chair tout ce qui
appartient mariage tourner sous devrait
travaux
bush master va brûler tous ceux qui se
mettront sur la route qui mène à maria
harlem peut gérer qu'un démon à la fois
mais ma plaque de respecter les règles
je suis celle que je suis désormais
on peut faire courir sur
non
tel sale boulot à notre place
elle fait
vous ne cessera jamais d'être un boy
scout
alors bien sûr que vous viendrez me
sourit
elle ne s'arrêtera jamais oyonnax
et personne d'autre que moi
parce que si ce n'est pas moi prié pour
que dieu sauve harlem prier pour qu'il
nous sauve tous